After the Russian army was
forced to retreat around Kiev.
The carnage came to light
Butcher board, Yanco
and many other Kiev suburbs
littered with bodies.
Ukraine especially blames
one Russian unit for alleged crimes here.
The 64th
separate guards motor
rifle brigade from eastern Siberia.
Now, a deserter from that unit
is speaking to CNN.
Actually, big lie for me like 24
February coming I think.
Okay
everyone goes to war.
Nikita Sebring defected
from the Russian military
and fled to Europe,
where we met him in a secret location.
He shows me his military booklet
with a stamp signed
by the commander of the 64th Motor
Rifle Brigade Colonel Azar Beck.
Ormeau Bake-Off.
Known in Ukraine
as The Butcher of Butcher,
Chipman says he and his comrades
were given shoot to kill orders.
Even though Russia has denied
any wrongdoing by its forces around Kiev.
I got one as well, but I'm like, I'm on.
We had a direct command to murder
those who divulged our positions.
If someone had a phone,
we were allowed to shoot him.
Kuban says the unit was deployed
to Belarus
shortly before the invasion,
allegedly for training.
The soldiers had no idea
they would soon advance into Ukraine,
and he says
they weren't prepared for war.
If you do you like around?
Everyone thought they could be like Rambo
Those who said I would be shooting
Ukrainians easily. Piece of cake.
When they went to the front line
and then they came back, they were like,
We don't want no war.
Jubrin says he, too,
came under Ukrainian artillery shelling
and showed us this video
from near the town
lip picker west of Kiev.
He tells me he refused to fight
because he was opposed to the war
and that his commanders
called him a coward
and reassigned him to menial
labor tasks in the rear echelon.
He says he didn't witness
the mass killings the unit is accused of,
but did witness plenty of crimes
against Ukrainian civilians,
including looting.
They weren't trying to hide it.
They did this very openly.
She is saying, look, you know,
this is so embarrassing what it is.
They say, whoa, I want to do this.
I want this.
The everything,
make the loot and cars
to make the looting
and even rape this individual.
I saw rapists running around being chased
because they were committed rape
the guys who did rape, I saw them run.
Then I learned they were rapists.
They raped a mother and daughter.
They were never jailed.
Just fired.
Just like that. Go.
CNN has reached out
to the Russian defense
ministry for comment,
but we haven't received a reply.
Russia has consistently denied
its forces were responsible for crimes
against Ukrainian civilians.
And President Vladimir Putin
issued a decree
praising the 64
separate guards, Motor Rifle
Brigade for, quote,
heroism and bold actions.
Nikita Chiba fled Russia while on leave.
He gets emotional
when talking about his four year
old daughter. He left behind.
He says he wants to testify
against his commanders
before an international court.
To shed light on
what happened in the war.
He never wanted to be a part of
and he said, Wolf,
the soldier said that discipline
was a huge issue in that unit.
He felt that the officers
were his commanders
in many cases, were indifferent
to the mission,
indifferent to their own soldiers,
and also, of course, indifferent
to the lives of the Ukrainians,
the civilians that were on the ground
there as well.
He also says
he doesn't believe that Russia
is going to be able to win the war.
He says also because the U.S.
and its allies are providing
that support to the Ukrainians.
And, of course, we'll continue
to provide that support as well.
He's obviously
one very courageous young man.
Fred Pleitgen,
thank you very much for that report.